donald trump soll angeblich wütend
gewesen sein auf seinen eigenen
stabschef mark madoffs der hat nach der
gestrigen pressekonferenz des
zehnköpfigen ärzteteams eigentlich den
ärzten fast widersprochen hat ist der
zustand des präsidenten sei nach wie vor
kritisch das hat momentan offensichtlich
extrem geärgert weil hier erst so
dargestellt wurde als wäre er wirklich
schwach und deshalb hat er auch dieses
video dann produziert das ihm zeigt als
entschieden führer von amerika und es
wird nach fotos veröffentlicht wo er am
schreibtisch sitzen und bearbeitet das
video wo natürlich auf der ganzen welt
ganz genau begutachtet ist sofort
aufgefallen trägt kein schlips zeigt
sich also etwas schwerer wenn man das in
dem fall überhaupt so sagen kann und
einige sagen man sieht ihm doch anders
die letzten tage nicht einfach waren
aber du hast es auch gesagt die
kommenden tage sind jetzt entscheiden
das wird immer wieder von den nächsten
48 stunden gesprochen
warum genau dieser zeitrahmen die
nächsten stunden sind tatsächlich
entscheidend weil jetzt die muss man
sagen wahrscheinlich die heiße phase der
carena virus erkrankung beginnt
offensichtlich hat sich der präsident
vor einer woche ungefähr angesteckt bei
diesem event im rosengarten jetzt eben
wurde er diagnostiziert so wenn man den
weißen haus glauben darf wahrscheinlich
erst am donnerstag da gab es auch ein
wenig verwirrung zuletzt und dann hat
eben die kranke die symptome begonnen
relativ dramatisch wie man jetzt weiß am
freitag und die nächsten tage sind
einfach so die dieser höhepunkt die
heiße phase dieser an einer typischen
carola virusinfektion sehr gern kommen
deshalb sind diese stunden so wichtig
und deshalb ist auch die hochspannung in
amerika die bleibt aufrecht in die
verwirrung die du gerade angesprochen
hast gibt es jetzt natürlich in den usa
das kann schon gesagt die die aussagen
der ärzte boden danach aus dem weißen
haus eigentlich schon wieder legt man
ist sich immer noch nicht ganz sicher
wie es donald trump wirklich geht wie
wird das in den usa aufgenommen merkt
man schon auswirkungen dessen dass es
ebenso eine um klarheit über den
gesundheitszustand ihres präsidenten
gibt
die reaktionen sind teilweise kritisch
in den amerikanischen medien natürlich
war einfach irre
dieses protokoll diese zeit linie immer
wieder anders dargestellt wird das hat
ja auch zuerst geheißen schon conley der
chefarzt hat ja zuerst gesagt der
präsident wäre 72 stunden nach seiner
diagnose
das hätte bedeutet dass er bereits am
mittwoch einen positiven test gehabt
hätte das wäre natürlich ein skandal
gewesen denn donald trump ist seinen
amtsgeschäften weiter nachgegangen
das wurde dann korrigiert möglicherweise
natürlich auf drängen des weißen hauses
der arzt selbst hat eine schriftliche
stellungnahme abgegeben dass er sich
versprochen hat dass er eigentlich 48
stunden gemeinsam nicht 72 stunden
das hat für kritik gesorgt natürlich und
insgesamt sind hier einfach zu viele
quellen zu viele menschen die hier
verschiedene dinge sagen es gibt
einerseits den stab selbst mark madoffs
der sich gleich nach der pressekonferenz
der ärzte die sehr gut gegangen die sehr
hoffnungsvoll lang hat sich marco
meadows an die an die preis und die
journalisten selbst gewarnt und hat ein
ganz anderes bild gezeigt und ein ganz
ein viel dramatischeres bild über den
gesundheitszustand
das wiederum wie vorher erwähnt hat
donald trump geärgert es ist ein hin und
her und auch eine sehr chaotische
reaktion des weißen hauses und des
staates auf diese wirklich schwere
möglicherweise schwere erkrankung dass
das präsident mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dir
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren